Where can I take you tonight, ma'am?
175 Springer Lane please.
You got it.
How about this weather?
It's really cold outside.
Are you warm enough or do I need to turn up the heater?
Oh no, I'm fine, but it's much colder here than I thought it would be.
Oh, are you from out of town?
Yes. It's much warmer where I'm from compared to Boston.
That sounds nice.
I can't wait for it to warm up here.
Where are you from?
I live in Atlanta.
I've been there a couple of times.
It is much warmer there.
Hey, didn't the Braves just win the National League Division Series?
Yes, they did, although the Dodgers didn't make it easy for them.
I'm not a baseball fan so I didn't watch any of the games.
But I heard it was real close.
It was but luckily the Braves came through in the last game.